recently I split up after a three year
and a half relationship I met her in
Spain I moved there started a business
kept through a few days literally she
moved in with me I was trying to to have
an idea how many guys she's been with
and she was like oh it could be in in 50
somewhere I literally don't have any
idea and she told me she suffered abuse
are we talking about a word that rhymes
with grape yeah I'm asking myself the
question am I broken because I broke up
or just because of the habit and because
we're not in contact anymore I have a
better question for you to contemplate
why are you inviting women like this
into your life you're going to have to
dig through a lot of dirt to find gold
and even if you do find gold it's going
to be more work if you keep playing this
game long enough some chick is going to
pull a number on you and I'm not saying
she's going to kill you but she's going
to do something that is going to put
your situation your life something
relationship with your brother in the
business at [__] risk you got to get
your head squared away my man you can't
allow these women because they're hot
pretty they're tens whatever to get away
with this stuff